I met Dwight Howard plays basketball but
I do know after Orlando he kind of got
distracted and was just never the same
player after that and that's because
he's been kneed deep in guys with wigs
on if you're a rich guy and you want to
have sex with anyone in this era Pat him
down make sure they don't have any
phones and make them sign a piece of
paper you have a gag order well you will
be sued I will deny this Stefan I'm
sorry uh Kitty what do you want to be
called put the wig on then Kitty comes
over hey boys hey Dwight I lost a lot of
money on you in that Orlando Chicago
Series in the early '90s since things
got a little to sprad please refer to me
as Kitty in my new line of work Dwight
Howard is officially coming out as gay
and this is probably not the way he
wanted to do it